it has been heralded alternately as a
Google killer and the most important
general purpose technology since the
wheel or fire chat GPT is an AI powered
chatbot whose answers honestly feel
human but the very feature that makes it
seem almost magical also poses a
colossal problem because we don't really
know where its answers are coming from
foreign
let's start with the basics chat GPT is
built by openai a company that's backed
by Microsoft and it's more or less free
for anyone to use
it works by ingesting hundreds of
gigabytes of Text data on which it is
then trained to generate human-like
responses it's pretty mind-blowing this
is an essay that it wrote about Romeo
and Juliet this is some software code it
can even generate jokes that are almost
funny crucially it works differently
from Google it doesn't just quote
sources verbatim and present it to you
instead it works much the way a human
would if I've taken an undergraduate
course in say critical theory and
someone asked me about the German
sociologist teodor adorno I will dig
into the recesses of my memory and cough
up an answer I might not necessarily
know the exact source of that answer
some book or lecture for more than a
decade ago frankly my answer might not
be entirely accurate chat GPT is similar
it doesn't cite a source the way that a
responsible journalist or academic would
Google for all of its justifiable
criticism for the way that it scrapes
data from other websites and presents
them on its own platforms does at least
cite the source same with Wikipedia here
if you read an article that feels a
little bit sketchy you can click through
the source and find for yourself whether
you think it is accurate and Beyond just
checking the veracity of any information
The Source itself doesn't get any credit
that might be less incentive to post
things online if it's just being scraped
by some AI algorithm this is a bigger
issue with AI as a whole the very nature
of deep learning is such that often the
system itself doesn't know the source of
the information that it's presented
chat GPT is just a beta for the moment
maybe some of these issues can be fixed
but that's also why it's worth
discussing them right now
[Music]